thanks for hanging out with us America
Kristen is in Tampa Florida hi Kristen
how are you hi good how are you better
than I deserve what's up well me and my
husband have been doing Dave ish for
probably about six years we've made some
progress but I still feel like we're
kind of not on the same page I've done
financial piece the home study we do
every dollar but we make very good money
and we're still 155 K and hole I think
we're gonna go ahead and do financial
piece a live course together he agreed
to do that but I just don't I I'm to the
point where I started to reinvest into
my retirement because I'm scared that we
won't have an ethic okay how can I help
[Music]
is it okay for me to be putting into my
retirement at this point well you're an
adult it's certainly legal well you know
if you're asking me is that what I teach
you know what I teach right and you know
that's not it
how do I get my husband's on board but
he's very passive about it he's active
about it I've tried doing the cash flow
system where I take out money for
groceries but then for example like last
week you need to sit down with him with
candles lit and the kids in bed and the
TV off and tell him he needs to man up
that you're tired of living with a dead
fish
how's that sound that sounds brutal
doesn't it you just told me your husband
was passive that's like the worst
possible thing you could say about a guy
a passive man who grows all right you
know you guys have got to sit down and
decide here's the thing he is passionate
about some things passionate about you
that's how you got married or at least
at one time he was how long you been
married ten years okay
what does he love to do more than
anything what's his favorite sport he
had back injury and that kind of also
kind of put us in a hole so what does he
love I did what's his passion kids okay
our kid so he's not a dispassionate
person he just he just is not passionate
about this subject yes okay so okay I
agree with whatever yeah and so what you
got to do is tell them guys are thick we
don't do subtlety you have to do you
have to come right straight at us it's
the only way we hear you and so you need
to take these two hands in your hands
and say it's not okay that you're not
involved in this I need you to be my man
I need you to walk with me and the two
of us carry this together with some
enthusiasm you standing on the sidelines
like a wet dishrag and saying whatever
you want to do honey be the only adult
in the house is not okay with me anymore
I'm done with this it's time that we go
to this class together it's time we both
get on this horse
and we both kick this horse until it
runs and when you say that to a guy
straight in his face he will hear you
because he loves you he loves those kids
and he's not a dispassionate person he
just isn't real enthused about this
particular subject but when you tell him
how important it is to you and it's
important to the family that he carry
his part of this family he will do it
he just needs some instruction and some
real direct requests from you my wife
passively saying I wish the garbage
would carry itself out doesn't work she
looks at me and says if you carry out
the garbage that would be really sexy
the garbage is on the curb I mean that's
not what you said though you is not
about his work ethic it's about whether
or not he's committed to make this
family's finances go ahead and get out
of debt and build some wealth and get
some stability and it's just passive
about that he wants you to do all the
work and you don't wanna do all the work
by yourself anymore you're tired of that
and you need to say so okay he's not a
bad guy I was picking my mother's making
fun of you okay okay he's not a bad guy
he's a good guy but guys are thick you
have to just tell us stuff we don't do
subtlety you just have to say it like it
is I this what I need you to do these
three things when you do these three
things you're sexy when you don't do
these three things you are not sexy guys
get that guy guys get that we're not
we're not we're pretty simple machines
okay and then so you're gonna go this
class you're gonna smile and you're
gonna help me with this and you're gonna
stick to the budget that we work
together as a matter of fact you could
actually lead in this whole equation and
wow I would be so impressed with you
were you to actually lead in this
equation instead of having me be the
only adult in the neighborhood I don't
want to be that anymore and he it's not
because he's not an adult it's just
because you got to let him know he's not
carrying his half of this and you are
now demanding that he does not as a wage
you know you're not as a witch because
you're not a witch and not as a nag
because you're not a nag
you're just communicating clearly what
your feelings are and I think I'm
reading your mail am i yeah okay all
right so you guys go to Financial Peace
University live no more ish yeah and
there's no shortcuts or you can't drive
around the barn three times you got to
go through the barn submit to the plan
this is how you get out of debt why so
that we can build wealth and send our
kids to college
why
so we can have a good life and be
generous why because this is how it
works the other crap doesn't work it's
frustrating it's stressful you worry you
you think about retirement you think
about kids you think about student loan
debt 40 20 years from now that they're
gonna be paying you think about money
too much yeah when you don't have a plan
you call it's called worry yes then you
need a plan and be executing towards the
plan and then the worry goes away and
you can get there you can do it you can
do this so ya go to the Financial Peace
University clutch you got it already
scheduled it sounds like do that but
have some real clear communication with
him that you need him to carry his part
of this equation as part of this
marriage I want you to be passionate
about this for the good of our family
budgeting is sexy you know that that's
the message that's what you say and you
know it works it works works works works
it's not manipulative it's just clear
communication and both of you then have
to stick to it once you get him going
he's gonna call you out when you start
screwing around too I mean you start
messing around on this you start no no
we're on the plan now you put me on the
plan well plan we're not going to eat
he's gonna be calling you out so be
careful what you wish for
but no more ish ish doesn't work and
it's not Dave ish it's you know submit
yourself to a proven system and when you
do that you'll get the results good
question it's fun talking to you thanks
for calling it